hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Game of Thrones episode 3 video
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen it yet so many huge things
happening in this episode couple really
awesome fanservice payoffs Tower of joy
style they definitely held back on that
the real fanservice payoff was at the
end so let's just do top 10 WTF and I'll
explain some of the big book changes
they had with these big payoff moments
because Tarot joy had a couple book
changes there was some Aria changes and
a few big Rick and stark changes so here
we go number 10 they think you're some
kind of God I love the way they opened
this episode just with the sound of
heavy breathing is John's heavy
breathing and Davos is being silent but
you think it's him because it's so close
up on his eyes like they're gonna pop
out of his head oh my god he's back
number 9 WTF though when mello Sanders
questioning him and he's like no I
didn't see anything but she says the
Lord brought you back for a reason
Stannis was not the prince who was
promised that is one of the biggest R +
L equals J Easter eggs that we've gotten
in a long time aside from the actual
Tower of joy flashback in that Lyanna
stark flashback last week they're all
just coming in rapid succession now like
the universe is slowly lining the clues
up so if you've never heard of the
prophecy of the prince who was promised
I just did a video about R + L equals J
I'll put a link in the description it's
a little complicated it was originally
written in high Valyrian which is
gender-neutral so it could go one of two
ways like Daenerys could be the prince
who has promised Jon Snow could be the
prince who was promised that I love the
way they used tormund Giantsbane in ed
is like the pressure relief valve of
course you're not a god a God wouldn't
have a picker that small all that Jon
Snow at the beginning of the episode
just complete female fanservice maybe
that's like a Mother's Day gift to all
the mothers out there here's some naked
and Confused Jon Snow for you talking
about his dick the EDD comment was
pretty interesting to where he's like
are you sure that's still you and there
that's just going to beric Dondarrion
when he said that every time he came
back from the dead a little piece of him
was left behind so he's still Jon Snow
just not the exact same Jon Snow that we
knew before they actually did a pretty
good job this week with setting up clues
for where the characters are going how
they're changing the challenges they're
facing speaking of where you're headed
oh we finally catch up with Samwell and
Gilly who is puking his way to Old Town
I love the way gillies taking it like a
total pro
can't wait to get there it's gonna be so
amazing oh wait hold up the old maesters
they're a bunch of grumpy old men
there's no way they're gonna let you in
that Country Club so now we know how
we're gonna meet samwell's family at
horn Hill his father is actually one of
the best military commanders in Westeros
he has a Valyrian sword called heart's
pain in the way he's described in the
books and the way Sam walls talked about
him on the TV show he sounds like he's
so gruff that he would make Tywin
Lannister sound like this big cuddly
teddy bear so it's gonna be a lot of fun
watching Samwell tried to explain Gilly
and the baby to his family that it was
really touching the way Gilly called
Samwell the father of her child even
though he's not the biological father
they are more of a family to Sam well
than his actual family that's what that
whole moment was about but getting into
the really interesting stuff
number seven WTF Tower of joy flashback
I love the way the three-eyed Raven was
narrating the brand instantly recognizes
his father but the way they explained
this scene is that bran has heard all
these stories about what happened during
Robert's rebellion but the fun of this
scene is in the difference between what
you've heard in what actually happened
so there were a couple big book changes
to the way this fight went down so the
big twist where Howland Reed saved Ned
Stark from being killed is actually
accurate the big change was that Arthur
Dayne is dual wielding and he's not
using dawn the ancestral blade of house
Dayne so I can understand if a lot of
people are upset that they didn't do
dawn on the TV show but if you have
absolutely no idea what that is it's an
ancient blade it's thousands and
thousands of years old
it's crafted from a fallen meteorite so
it's not Valyrian steel but it's just as
strong as Valyrian steel and it gives
off this dull glow so it's almost like
Game of Thrones version of an actual
lightsaber but the three-eyed Raven is
also book accurate when he describes
Arthur Dayne as being a much better
fighter like the best fighter so the way
Dan and Dave explained like their
interpretation of this moment is is that
Ned Stark believed in his honor so much
that he was willing to die an Arthur
Dayne sword during this battle but
Howland Reed of course came to his
senses like we need to kill him because
it's gonna kill us in the NED
recognizing his sister just kind of
snapped inside so then he goes running
after of course they're not gonna show
us everything in this episode I wasn't
surprised I was hoping that we would get
a little bit more than what we actually
got but I can understand how they're
holding
back they just don't want everyone to
blow their r+ l equals J load right away
this is only episode three there's gonna
be ten episodes this season we'll
probably get the rest of this later
just like the three-eyed Raven says
don't stay too long you definitely won't
want to come back and when he says bran
needs to learn everything like capital e
everything he's talking about White
Walkers the great other the red God the
war for the dawn like Lily like all the
things that you wish that George are
Martin would explain but has not done
yet number six WTF though more R plus l
equals J confirmation why weren't you at
the Trident protecting your prince our
Prince wanted us here so I like the way
they imply that had they been at the
Trident Robert would not have been able
to kill Rhaegar their side wouldn't have
lost the battle but like they said
Rhaegar wanted them there and like I
said I go into a little bit more detail
on that in the r plus l equals j video
that had just posted there's a link in
the description but I think now knowing
that Arthur Dayne wasn't using dawn Ned
did not take dawn to star fall you can
cross ashara dayne
off of your jon snow motherless let you
I mean like I said I've clearly backed R
+ L equals J but there are certain
moments that allow you to eliminate
other choices number 5
everybody in slavers Bay vs. team
Daenerys or Daenerys small Council
however you want to think about them we
learn the good masters the wise masters
basically the powers the Daenerys has
defeated thus far are all teaming up in
funding the sons of the harpy which when
you think about it ties in really nicely
with what's going on with Daenerys
storyline the way they talk about how
the new Khal has to decide which cities
to sack so very clearly Daenerys is
gonna have to win over the Dothraki and
they'll use the Dothraki to pacify
slavers Bay number four we learn about
bears as little birds which are now Chi
burns little birds I love the way
they're also openly addressing zombie
mountain the big book change here is
that zombie mountain in the books after
he becomes zombie mountain isn't called
Gregor Clegane anymore they refer to him
as Robert strong in parade him around
just pretending that he's a new knight
of the Kingsguard so the show isn't even
bothering to keep up that fiction even
the small council is like we can't
believe what you did with this
monstrosity this is an abomination are
you gonna make it murder all of us
so the problem right there you saw it
instantly is that Kievan lannister just
broke
one of the cardinal rules of a horror
movie so they're all probably going to
be murdered maybe by some of the little
birds but the other big thing with the
little birds is that now sir she's just
gonna be spreading them all over the
kingdom so she'll just have access to
information so that's probably how she's
gonna find out what's going on in the
north with Ramsey the big snow bowl that
we might be getting later funniest
moment in the episode though was pycelle
just going on and on and on then the
zombie mountain walks in as he's talking
about him and turns around sees him and
farts it's just one of the funniest
moments ever or you could say that it
was mace Tyrell that farted someone
sitting there was just so afraid of the
mountain that they completely lost it
and [ __ ] their pants
number 3 wTF is already getting her
sight back it was actually a pretty
badass montage and when the music
swelled up in the camera panned in just
like tell you visually that she was a
badass it sounded a lot like the music
when Jon Snow was resurrected but they
actually did a pretty good job during
this storyline of checking in with
Westeros they asked her about her family
they could be dead for all the girl
knows they mentioned the Hound yes a
girl was confused and then when jaqen
gives her her sight back this is
actually a big change for the books in
the books they just keep giving her a
special potion to make her blind the TV
show made it seem a little more
supernatural and there is a supernatural
component to the faceless mens
techniques but this actual moment like
the way she gets her eyesight back is
just a small change from the books big
change from the books though number 2
WTF is that Rickon has been with the
umbers they betrayed House Stark and
they killed shaggy-dog that was the
moment that almost made me scream out
loud not the Rick and an OSHA reveal the
shaggy-dog reveal that was just like oh
my god no because it reminds you of Robb
Stark incur a wind it's just like how
many dire wolves do we have left now
just to check in we have ghosts we have
summer and we have Nymeria Arya's dire
wolf is still alive and running around
George our Martin confirmed that the
super pack does exist they might end up
doing it on the TV show no idea when we
would see it if it be this season or
next season but there are three dire
wolves that are still alive if you're
wondering what's going on with the
umbers there's a nice parallel between
the betrayals in the north of the houses
in what's going on with Daenerys
storyline in the east it's all about old
ways versus the new ways people throwing
tradition away in good ways and bad ways
like Daenerys has be
a victim of the Dothraki traditions so
she's basically telling these Doge clean
look I'm a queen I've done all these
things they're like no no no no no
that's not the way of things you're
meant to do this with us so sometime
this season Daenerys is gonna have to
cast away the old Dothraki traditions
like the bad traditions but then you
have the [ __ ] sons of the northern
Lords who have now become lords
themselves and are saying screw this I'm
not kneeling I'm not doing any of this
this is [ __ ] I hate wildlings let's
all team up and kill them
so the wildlings are the whole reason
that the umbers betrayed the Starks
because they just they hate the
wildlings so they're willing to do
anything to get rid of them and if you
were confused this is small John umber
Greatjon number is the one that worked
with Robb Stark and I think we talked
about the Karstarks last week Robb Stark
made enemies of them when he beheaded
the former Lord Karstark so they've
hated the Starks for a while now
small John umber just saw an opportunity
and took it and he just he doesn't care
anything about traditions so people
casting away traditions breaking O's
just like Jon Snow did in bad ways and
good ways like there are bad traditions
there are good traditions he was even
present during varus's conversation when
he was asking the woman about what was
going on with the harpies she was really
afraid of Daenerys rolling into marine
and changing all their traditions
throwing away their history obviously
that's [ __ ] because Daenerys was
trying to make things better for people
Farris tells her and this kind of goes
for what happens at the end of the
episode to look either we find a
compromise or that's it for you you're
definitely gonna die what's your son
gonna do without his mother and the
other big book change here is where Rick
and and OSHA show up so in the books
they're hiding out on the Isle of Skye
goes they appear via house Manderly in
white Harbor with Lord too fat to sit a
horse the TV show isn't doing that
character it looks like it hasn't done
house Manderly so they gave that part of
the story to house umber just in the way
they gave heed Rick storm's storyline to
Gendry on the TV show so number one WTF
I'm actually gonna cuss a little bit so
if you have a problem with foul language
you could just skip ahead a little bit
but this is the [ __ ] ollie moment so
this is complete fanservice let me know
how many of you are gonna make this your
phone lock screen or your desktop screen
saver it wasn't a moment that I expected
but when you see that look on Ali's face
like he just he hates John to the very
last Alastair Thor and goes out like a
chant though I picked my battle
lost I do the same thing again I
understand what you have to do my watch
is ended but you're gonna be defending
these people for forever which I felt
like was a small joke about him being
immortal Jon Snow is only functionally
immortal as long as Melisandre can bring
him back so given that beric Dondarrion
came back six times it'll be interesting
to see how many times Jon Snow can go
down and Melisandre will still be able
to bring him back but I don't think he's
gonna be going all Wolverine anytime
soon like I think this is probably the
last time we've seen him die for a great
while he might go down again before the
end of the season but but they're not
gonna do like a funny montage where he
just dies over and over and over and she
just keeps bringing him back but he left
the watch and edy is now the new Lord
Commander so the big question is is will
Jon snow slowly converge with what
sonses doing because it seems like she's
headed a house Mormont we've seen Davos
inside their Great Hall so you know
maybe their storylines will converge for
now I guess he's just gonna be hanging
out with the wildlings figuring out what
to do next so I think the biggest
question of the night even though they
didn't officially pay it off do you feel
like between what Melisandre said her
comments about the prince who was
promised as well as the Tarot joy
flashback in some of the language that
they use in the way they show things do
you think that that is confirmation of
our plus L equals J even if it's not
fully confirmed I feel like they're
stacking the deck in favor of that
so just remains to be seen when they're
gonna finish paying off that moment but
there is a new round of the giveaway
this week all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video what I'm gonna do next is
there's a couple more Civil War videos
that I have to do but I will be doing a
Q&A for this so leave all your questions
in the comments there's just like so
many exciting things and so many payoffs
that happen to this episode even even
though Tara joy was in a full payoff
it's still a pretty big payoff in the
Olly payoff was just really nice - that
was just the icing on the cake it made
me feel a little bit better about what
happened to shaggy-dog still just a
little salty about shaggy-dog but well
you guys wait for my next video to post
you can click here for that you know big
R + L equals J Tower of joy explainer
prince who was promised prophecy it's
all really exciting and you can click
here for all my Captain America Easter
eggs thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you